[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con se cumplen
seis meses del break sheet el retiro del
reino unido de la unión europea y que
puso una nueva forma de relacionamiento
entre londres y bruselas a todo nivel
comercial político sanitario y hasta
tecnológico seis meses han pasado y es
el momento de hacer un primer balance
para ello está con nosotros césar
jiménez analista político internacional
y académico de la universidad de cardiff
señor jiménez buen día para ustedes y
por favor para comenzar denos un rápido
balance de lo positivo y lo negativo que
ha dejado el break city
muchas gracias angela por la invitación
yo creo que lo primero es que
hay que siempre recordar que el éxito no
es un evento sino que es un proceso es
un proceso muy lento por lo tanto ni las
predicciones apocalípticas de quien
estaban en contra del proceso ni tampoco
los beneficios inmediatos de quien
apoyaban a brasil e iban a ser evidentes
inmediatamente son lo primero
lo otro es muy difícil en este momento
realizar un análisis objetivo de presido
porque muchas de las consecuencias que
podrían verse en el día a día de los
británicos también en la economía o la
política están tapadas debido a los
efectos de la pandemia de corden a virus
entonces es difícil separar actualmente
si por ejemplo lo que está ocurriendo
económicamente se debe a la pandemia
hombres y habiendo dicho eso hay una
batalla de narrativas en el reino unido
está por un lado el gobierno que dice
que está por la adición perfecta
correcta y en parte dicen que el
programa de vacunación del reino unido
fue exitoso a raíz del break sit y está
también otra narrativa que presta
atención a todos los detalles económicos
y controles
están ocurriendo de momento en el
reunido a raíz de la falta de claridad o
del fin de acuerdos con la unión europea
bueno y que tanto cambió la forma en la
que se relacionan ahora a londres y
bruselas londres perdió un aliado o
bruselas perdió un sucio
yo creo que los dos han perdido mucho yo
creo que la evaluación que se hizo
apenas ocurrió el referéndum esa
evaluación desde la unión europea que
decía que el break city y las
negociaciones son un ejercicio de
contención y donde no hay ganadores creo
que eso lo cierto creo que la unión
europea está más débil pero también el
reino unido- internacionalmente está en
una posición mucho más frágil también y
dónde va a tener que tomar decisiones a
largo plazo de si se va a acercar a la
unión europea políticamente nuestras
relaciones o va a buscar tomar otra ruta
bueno y si bien es difícil hacer una
medición económica por efectos de la
pandemia para usted
operativamente cuál ha sido el sector
más afectado y que ha costado más
restablecer o mantener el comercial el
financiero el político
de momento ha habido muchos efectos en
pequeñas y medianas empresas en el reino
unido es bastante trágico que en la
campaña del referéndum una de las
grandes excusas que ponían quienes
apoyaban al próximo era proteger la
pesca el reunido sin embargo ese sector
ha sido particularmente afectado con
muchas compañías que perfectamente
podría estar en la quiebra
también hay varias otras compañías
pequeñas que tenían en posiciones con
en unión europea que están cerrando su
negocio han disminuido el problema es
que muchas veces de esas noticias
ya no son portadas en el reino unido
aparecen al final de los noticiarios o
aparecen en la página 30 o 40 de un
diario entonces no son parte de la
discusión del día a día
lo que sí ha hecho noticia últimamente
son por ejemplo el hecho de que los
músicos británicos
ya no tienen la misma libertad y
facilidad para hacer giras por la unión
europea y ha habido una controversia el
último diente
elton john y lord foster ministro
negociador de de relaciones con la unión
europea
últimamente bueno y ya para el cierre
seis meses después que elecciones se
deja para el reino unido- haberse
retirado de la unión europea
yo creo que una de las principales
lecciones es
a nivel interno hay una articulación
completa de las políticas en el reino
unido- eso se vio en las elecciones
generales del año 2019 donde si bien en
encuestas los gritan a ti los británicos
dicen estar cansados del éxito si hay un
cambio de identidad política y las
líneas de izquierda derecha o laborista
conservador ya no son tan claras y hay
una identidad política más asociada a
estar a favor en contra de práctica
junto con eso hay una consecuencia muy
importante que se refiere al futuro
mismo del reino unido que indudablemente
break sit he echado fuego a la causa
independista escocesa entonces pues se
puede ser una de las quizás la
consecuencia más importante de presido
muchas gracias a ser jiménez desde el
reino unido y a nuestros televidentes
sigan en france24
[Música]